[Music]
everyone here loves music yes
we're music lovers music oh music
oh interesting you play that kind of
music oh well this one is it techno
i can't do it
[Laughter]
new research has come out to say that
they can
pretty much prove that it is
nearly impossible for you
to not move when there is dance music
playing
but there's a lot of people that don't
like dance music even if you don't like
it
it's nearly impossible for you to stay
completely still i've been to clubs
where the guys just stand in a corner
and the best music is playing and
they're just in the corner that's me
yeah that's what i'm saying this is
wrong the guy with the drink that's
empty because i already finished it but
i'm still like
that is so not you casey you always
above
your head like okay so we're saying like
no head nod no
foot tap you can talk about completely
no even if you're actively trying to be
completely still it's nearly impossible
i believe it because
i remember when i was trying to be a
little too cool back in the day
and i was like because i love dancing
right but there was a phase when i was
like
dancing is not for men yeah right
gangsters
don't dance we boogie right so i was on
the um
hold on a second what's the book i don't
know but
that was the that was the model right we
boogie okay we don't [ __ ]
dance all right there's a song called
gangster boogie yogi
yeah but i remember i loved music so
much
that i had to flex that one cheek to the
[ __ ] beat
so even though i'm standing there i'm
just like your
yeah my butt cheek yeah my butt cheek
you're you're squeezing one you're just
like
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] the [ __ ] hair
i can't i can't control the times that i
want to dance
it's weird you can't no so like so like
let's say i go to a club right and then
like i hear music it's my favorite music
i dance this all the time in the shower
by myself
and then sometimes i'm there everyone's
dancing i feel safe
and my body doesn't want to dance and
then sometimes uh like i'm at the gym
no one's dancing everyone's being
serious as [ __ ] and i just start dancing
and i don't even want to dance i'm
trying to get serious too but [ __ ]
just like
you're like oh we danced non-concord
like sometimes i want to dance and i can
dance and someone's like can't dance i
want
it's just weird i don't know why i'm
dancing all the time all the time but i
always want to dance yeah
and i like dancing yeah you know what i
wish i could do is dance like like
how tycho would dance because like i
don't know like it as a different
man yeah you can't just go yeah you
could do whatever
yeah you can go yeah you can i don't
know
what do you think joe does i feel
confident about myself that's true
that's true joe doesn't care too much
you just
there's nothing better than have you
been to have you been to a rave or
never i've only been to the club and at
the club you feel like you got to like
bust out the moves that looks cool or
like the girls will appreciate you gotta
go
you probably would love like house trans
progressive
deep house those types because everybody
literally is there with the i don't care
about the world
the lights are going and even if you
don't do drugs or don't drink you're in
the environment and the energy is there
like if you get high off of the energy
there
yeah cause you'll see people dancing
like that and you're like they're so
free i want to be like them
especially the white people oh they go
hard that's true even off beat too i was
like how's that impossible
there's no beat out it's just this i was
like how do you dance
and then there's no beat and then
there's the type that you there's so
i worked at a nightclub in san francisco
and one of the rooms was the
deep house room and there is light so
imagine looking at the scene like
looking at the floor and looking at the
ceiling there's all
lights and they play with the music and
it's a smaller room
and the djs literally are playing like
after our music
where it's like then you're like
you're in there and everybody's just in
their own zone like you can watch the
lights and you're just
moving with it and you wouldn't do that
at the hip-hop side of the room
you need more
[Music]
don't grind your nuts on to me it's the
hip-hop side
that's the feeling i get it's like i'm
here to grind my
nuts hip-hop besides and i'm about to
twerk my booty nah
hip-hop side is grab your bottle wrap
all the lyrics
to the song that we gonna be like this
in this [ __ ] give me the bottles give
me this because i definitely will be
that girl sitting on a couch
occasionally
heels up like i'm here sending my bottle
but you can always tell where people are
from depending on how they dance because
a
suit girls from the bay dance a little
different they don't we don't get [ __ ]
are you from the bay i stay in the bay i
always have to clarify that stayed in
the bay worked in san francisco for like
10 years
so when i'm out there we dance we don't
give a [ __ ] like you're dancing we're
very diverse so when we're in la you can
tell you're like you're not from here
but when you're in l.a they pretend they
don't like i feel like they just hold
drinks
i feel like la is a little bit more it's
like siddie a little bit more like
you know you're dressed who's seen me i
want to be seen my outfit is
different but when you go out to certain
places like house club
turn up have fun we're drinking and then
you go to places like san francisco when
we party out there we're like
dancing everybody's just like really lit
turned up but like this is a natural
motion to have a bottle in your hand
yeah
and you're more likely to be rapping all
the the songs
that's true but like grinding maybe if
you're on the dance floor but i ain't
going on that damn dance floor like
ladies you will get like yeah yeah yeah
yeah
wow i was in austin and i was like wow
they really go hard out here like we got
yeah in texas it was like you go in
and everyone's [ __ ] throwing their
butt at you and then when you leave
girls have no shoes and all of their
makeup is melted
because they go hard
like you don't see that in l.a school
dances it was literally
like girls falling over because guys are
pushing them over from grinding or vice
versa guys are falling backwards because
the girls are trying to bump up
that's a style like i said depending on
where you are because in the bay you'll
go and everybody's
dancing but ain't nobody really like
because i know exactly what you're
talking about you know
when you're dancing you grab you
grabbing them and you're like ah girls
we danced like that with each other i
have been so bad in that club
so so so bad in the club but it's like a
hybrid
we'll go and i you go and you dance with
them you guys don't have manners
except i owe it [ __ ] don't leave the
club with no shoes on
nasty nasty barefoot girls that's the
floor
the floors there's nasty stuff on there
i've seen people do nasty things in the
club and if you put your feetsies on it
you're going to catch
all of it oh all right gross so back to
this
research here this new research so they
were studying
um micro movements in the body
and like like what activates it and
stuff so they're saying that when you
try to stand
completely still on average you sway
your head
seven millimeters per second you do
seven millimeters
yeah so even just the act of breathing
makes you move you know
like there's just there's no way you
can't move out that's true so they don't
take that in account then
um maybe they're doing this maybe
they're even saying you breathe on beat
or something
no so then they were they were saying
that they were looking into like all
kinds of genres
and all types of like um ethnicity or
not
but like age groups and stuff and and
preferences
and all the graphics they should look at
all kinds of ethnicities i feel like
every culture has a way of expressing
that
dance you know like if you're filipino
they're going to start break dancing
you know true if you're like japanese
you're just going to start like pablo
well they do mention that body control
and your relationship with music makes a
difference
um and even people who are tone deaf
or like hopelessly like musically
challenged
whatever yeah this is where you do this
yeah even even like no matter who it is
when it comes to specifically the genre
of dance
music it's virtually impossible to not
have
any sort of micro movement because of
the beat yeah the beat so the rhythm
the rhythm the type of rhythm that comes
with dance music
it's just it ends up like syncing up
with our
what's dance music
not quite right but close
[Laughter]
i think like dance stands for evolution
every time i think of house music
yourself to be like empathetic people
like and like
yeah that's how i can feel your pain
only if they they're saying something
that actually makes me empathize
no not really naturally i don't give a
[ __ ] but i'll pay attention every once
in a while yeah so they're saying that
those people who had a high score in
respect of their emotional responses
such as empathy
moved more than others because does that
mean i'm empathetic
to like emphasize and like you yeah like
you're showing people a higher degree of
empathy that
and so you're mirroring what people like
would be doing so then you relate more
to the surroundings so then if other
people are
also moving to the music so the loner in
the corner is an
[ __ ] maybe is that what we're getting
like the guy who's totally
not moving not doing anything is lacks
empathy
probably who knows maybe he has a
different relationship with music
right maybe he's scared maybe maybe it's
maybelline
they're just waiting for joe to come out
there and say give me your
hand oh that's what it is that's what it
is they're playing hard to get
okay yeah but i found that so
interesting and and so this research
group they even
they they held this this like
competition to see
no dance competition who can stand the
still
the chinese guy chinese guy these guys
like how do they how do they lose they
just bust out and dance they're like i
can't take it anymore down
could you imagine that yeah so
they called it norwegian championship
stand still
norwegian it would be the whitest
country in the world
one more time norwegian championships of
standstill of
standstill yeah that could sound like a
norwegian town or city i'm stand still
yeah they're calling it a series of
norwegian championship of standstill
and they found that the participant who
won like the record breaker
only swayed 3.9 millimeters per second
wow they do it by the millions i don't
even know how to stand still
period yeah that's true wow think about
it how many times do you like bend your
knees or just
oh no no like shift your weight around
we would lose all of us who
lost insulin especially when i was a kid
i had adhd like heavily
and i remember like even inside my shoes
if my like my toes needed to be
constantly like
moving like i could not even my body
like my hands i had to always be like
fidgeting for some reason
so i would definitely yeah i'm losing
i'm losing that not even close i'm not
even signing up for the competition nor
am i
watching that what type of [ __ ] is that
that's the most boring thing to watch
i know i would love to see it though
like i just want to see what that looks
like that's full move more ready this is
what it looks like
they got the most hype is music and it's
just like five dudes like just
your [ __ ] michael jackson moonwalk
performance
oh yeah to see if they have empathy you
just see everybody's like
no and then they also we're looking at
the differences between like
listening to the music in the room or in
your headphones and when you have them
in your headphones you do tend to move
way
[Laughter]
myself i'm like yeah nobody knows what's
going on right now
when you listen to sad music in your
headphones and you're like pretending
you're in a music video
with the rain falling i'll be killing it
in my car
singing i can sing or dance both nice i
got the moves
i'm pretty good when no one's listening
but when people start listening i don't
know what happens me too
they make us sing on no chaser oh they
did
they we sing every time tim and rick
because those [ __ ] can actually sing
oh they can [ __ ] sing and they know
oh no
see you can't sing like some hawaiian
folk songs
[Laughter]
that was pretty good it's pretty good
we're going to hokey lau i see he hear
you he said so we going
no i mean i can a little bit but those
guys they got they can sing
literally rick will be hitting them
notes
sing tim can sing and so can rick
i just be chiming in occasionally but
they used to [ __ ] me up because those
two are like
in sync with each other they're best
buds they're best buds and i'm sitting
there like
y'all gonna keep picking songs i had no
idea and so it became things i never
knew the words and i started knowing the
words and
nice i do yeah i just keep trying to
pretend like
thousands of people aren't listening to
me sing and because the moment you think
about it
you